thank you very much for having me
um
uh it's it's great to to visit here
and
i'm from
carnegie mellon school of computer
science and um
i will give you an introduction of our
recent work in developing computational
methods for
3d genome in particular for a single
cell
3d genome in the past couple of decades
we have seen you know tremendous
progress in computational biology for
analyzing genome sequence and also
functional genomic data
but the type of data that we have been
dealing with
as you know are
not really capturing the in-situ
patterns of the biomolecules and also
cells in a way that they're typically
you know flattened without their spatial
contacts dna sequence is a linear string
or gene expression is just as a matrix
so as you know recently there are a lot
of experimental development in high
throughput methods to probe the spatial
organization
of both the chromatin and also the cells
but there are pressing computational
challenges yesterday we heard about
spatial
transcriptomics you know from from
shannon and martin
and my group we are also very interested
in that and developed some some methods
on that but i won't talk about that
today today i will focus on the intra
cellular
organization in particular uh the
intranuclear spatial organization
collectively i call them
spatial biology or spatial
genomics
but sometimes it may be a little
confusing i was recently invited to give
a talk at nasa
and then i know that they're also
working on spatial biology but they're
dealing with something that
astronomically different in terms of
scale and then also distance
so our genome we have you know as we all
know have 23 pairs of chromosomes um
you know three about three billion base
pair uh sequence and they're actually if
you stitch all the dna together is about
six feet long two meters
uh but the cell nucleus is only about
five micrometer uh in size
and so the chromatins are packed and
folded into this teeny tiny little
cell nucleus
unfortunately the principles and
regulations of
this kind of organization
[Music]
are actually not quite clear still
in the past
10 15 years also
because of the development in high
throughput whole genome chromatin
interaction mapping methods like hi-c
we have learned quite a bit of the
the 3d genome organization in terms of
the features
and we know that
the 3d
organization is not a heterogeneous it
doesn't have a heterogeneous
pattern and the nucleus is is is has
various types of organelle
and it has mo it actually reflec has
multi-scale structures that you can
actually observe from
high c data uh for instance the
uh at the large scale the the chromatins
are organized into these so-called amb
compartments which largely correspond to
active in inactive chromatin
um and if you zoom in and you you're
going to see more fine scale structures
like chromatins are also organizing this
local
structure called topologically
associating domains where
the chromatins are interacting within
more frequently within the domain than
the surrounding
regions if you keep zooming in you're
going to see more fine scale structures
like these chromatin loops where you see
a uh
a dot you know off diagonal dot with
high intensity which reflects that those
two regions on the chromosomes are
spatially much more much closer to each
other than than the surrounding regions
of course you know these um
there are other types of more complex
and fine scale structures that you can
discover from the high c data and these
are just the three
very distinct levels of of structures av
compartment tabs and loops which i will
you know mention this
several times in the rest of the
presentation
and many computational methods have
already been developed to analyze these
these data as you
may
guess you know for
the datas itself it depends on the
coverage and that the resolutions that
you're looking at
for fine scale structures are loops you
really need more powerful methods to
identify them so i was always joking you
know some people just eyeballing these
these maps is really not reliable
because it depends on how much
coffee or alcohol you have you're going
to see different kind of
patterns from these from these maps so
you need more reliable methods to do
that um
one some of the um
our efforts um that my lab is working on
right now is in the context of an nih
consortium code for the nucleon there
are four major integrative analysis
centers in this consortium and we're in
the second year
and we're uh leading one of the four uh
centers which is headquarters at
carnegie mellon we have nine
investigators in different institutions
and our goal is slightly different than
the conventional high c-based you know
approaches where we try to map the
large-scale chromosome structures in
terms of their compromisation to major
nuclear bodies uh in the nucleus uh so
like nuclear nuclear the largest nuclear
body but there are
also other sub-nuclear structures like
nuclear space caja bodies pml bodies and
all these and some of the bodies have
yet to be uh discovered how chromatins
are interacting with these these uh
various types of nuclear bodies are
are
are
we have very limited knowledge so our
center of projects is to try to develop
both the genomic mapping
imaging-based approach together with
let's say physics based
structure modeling together with machine
learning based
integration methods to have a more
holistic view of the cell nucleus
for example last year we developed a
very actually very uh straightforward
approach based upon markov random field
by integrating high c data with the
genomic mapping where the genomic
signals reflect the distance or contact
frequency between the chromatin and the
particular nuclear body so the hidden
states here are the uh
spatial position in the nucleus relative
to multiple nuclear bodies and the
observations are the signals from the
from these the genomic mapping into in
particular the mid and also the tsa seek
signals i won't get into the details in
these athletes essays but if you're of
interest you can take a look at the at
the paper
so ultimately you basically try to
partition the genomes into these color
bars where each color bar represents a
distinct position in the nucleus
relative to multiple nuclear bodies and
these information drastically enhances
the a and b compartmentization i
mentioned to you on the previous slide
and provides further stratification of
various types of genomic and functional
genomic data
very importantly it's
key to connect the structural features
with functional properties within the
nucleus and
we
um the the the the analysis of the
interaction of with nuclear bodies
highlights the importance of of of
having a more more integrative lens to
look at these things in the nucleus um
so in this paper we we did about two
years ago what we did is to integrate
the uh 3d chromatin rack tone with
transcriptional regulatory network so in
a way that you can um start to um
see that these
these chromatins are are coming together
and at the same time the genes on these
chromosomes are being regulated by the
same set of transcription factors and
forming these very interesting
um hubs or some people or some sometimes
people call them nuclear condensates in
in the um in the in in the nucleus where
they have particular functions and and
also structural uh properties in this
work we actually developed a graph
mining approach to identify these
modules and it's in principle it is a
graph
partitioning approach but the difference
here is rather than
looking at uh try to minimize the you
know number of times you're
going through the edges you're actually
trying to minimize the number of times
you're cutting across a graph motif so
this is built upon early work from yuri
los kovich's lab at stanford
so these results are
interesting and they're providing news
perspectives of the nuclear structure by
looking at the data in different ways
but unfortunately they're they're you
know all these work so far most of the
work so far are based on bulk assays
like bulk high c or bulk
epigenomic assays they're not they're
not reflecting what's going on in single
cell
and that's what i wanted to introduce to
you uh today mostly so uh first you know
there are very recently their single
cell three genome mapping is an emerging
direction in epigenomic research and
there have been quite a bit quite a lot
a few you know uh single cell three
genome singles uh high c data um have
been published in the past um uh few
years
and in in in general they you know
there's some certain differences in in
terms of the experimental details like
how you actually incorporate the um
and you know for different cells how you
incorporate their
cell cell cells single cell specific
indices right you can incorporate in
different ways whether it's part of the
um only in the sequencing primers or you
also try to incorporate into uh the
ligation adapters uh for instance the
jay chandura and julian don's method i
think they try to incorporate both but
some of the other uh single cell high c
approaches are are handling this
different uh like uh sunny shias dipsy
they're uh doing this during the
amplification uh step but regardless of
the experimental technologies uh the
computational challenges are monumental
it's it's it's much more uh
uh um
challenging than the single cell rna seo
singleton taxi as you can see from these
kind of maps this is a bulk high c
contact maps that you have seen before
but these are single cell high c content
map they're extremely sparse
and uh because you know it's is two
dimensional you can only capture certain
interactions
and uh the number of reasons supporting
each interaction is is a small
and um there's also a lot of
dependencies among these different
entries and and their their noise but
they're there so far there there have
been some single cell high c analysis
methods and they typically follow these
two frameworks first is you want to
generate embeddings for each cell right
for each cell you have embedding you can
do subsequent analysis clustering and so
forth
second um
we typically also are interested in the
three genome features like introduced to
you in the beginning like a b
compartments or
tabs
at single cell level right if it's very
very sparse then there's no way to
identify them so one way to do that to
mitigate that is to let's do some
imputation you try to guess to impute
the missing values and then fill the
entries feel the empty entries in this
contact map such that you'll be able to
more reliably call
cards you know compartments and even
loops in single cells
so here's our uh solution and this is
mostly done by a graduating phd student
watcher
[Music]
so what we uh we had a so first of all
our approach is let me just because of
time limit i just directly go into the
solution so we
use this hyper graph formulation
as a solution to model high order
chromatin interactions
so we all know graph so you have nodes
and edges um hyper graphs you also have
nodes and edges nodes are you know nodes
and then they can have different
attributes
but edges you may it doesn't have to be
pairwise interactions you can have
multiple nodes to form these hyperedges
so if the hypergraph all the hyperedges
have the same
number of nodes and it's uniform you can
call it k unit form hypergraph but if it
it you know it doesn't have to be you
can have a more
a non-uniform heterogeneous hypograph as
well so hypographic you can you know for
instance there is an example
co-authorship so each node is an
individual a researcher let's say
but they have they may have different
roles right so co-authors or
corresponding authors and then each um
orange circle here represents
co-authorship and then that each orange
circle is the hyper edge
for example you can also model events
human location activity as in hyper edge
in hyper um and then you can you can uh
represent both the hyperedge and also
the nodes in the hypergraph um
in in in in in a lower dimensional space
um so the task is here is that for a
given hypergraph with features on each
node we uh want to learn the embeddings
of the node in the hypergraph
and then you can also learn to predict
whether um and hyperedge exists
for example if i give you some
individual in the context social network
if you know some individuals
online activity right what have what
type of posts they this individual has
liked you want to predict you know if i
give you three or four individuals
whether these four three individuals are
going to form a group chat for instance
so this this analogy here is exactly
what we're trying to achieve is using
their um the the attributes of the node
and together with their pairwise
interactions we may be able to predict
their high order
properties high order interactions
um so the the uh we had a solution what
we call hyper second and it was actually
published in the machine learning
conference uh uh earlier and then the
student uh wrote should know we came up
with an idea that you can actually use
this to model uh single cell high c data
so the key um
results or the key ideas really on this
part of the slide you model each so
these are
single cell single cell high c content
maps right each map is a sparse contact
map where if there is an entry
there it means that there's a read
from the single cell ic data supporting
that interaction
now for each entry in this
contact map we actually we can use a
hyperedge to represent that and where
each hyperedge
all the hyperedges will have
three nodes where one node is the cell
node and the other two are the genomic
pin node so one hyperedge here
represents
the fact that two genomic bins are
interacting with each other in a
particular cell
so in a way that all the or if you have
you're given a single cell high c data
set you can use one hypograph
to represent the entire data set right
where you have cell nodes you know you
have 1000 cells and you have 1000 cell
nodes and the genomic bins are you know
depending on your resolutions you'll be
able to have these genomic bing nodes
and the hyper edges are really referring
to the fact that these two genomic bins
are interacting with each other in a
given in a given cell
so
you can certainly generate embeddings of
the node of the cell node and then you
can do clustering let's say you can use
the the patterns of the single cell high
c to
uh study
you know how these cells are are what
are the subtypes of the cells and from
complex tissues i'll show you in a
minute
or you can
also do imputation where the imputation
becomes equivalent to
predicting the existence of the
hyperedge right because it's a missing
entry and you try to predict what is the
probability that these two genomic
things are interacting with each other
in a given cell
so with these these two basically uh we
um uh turn that these two problems i
mentioned to you on the previous slide
into embeddings of the cell and the
imputation of the of the contact map
and this was actually published recently
now showing some results um how this how
there are some earlier methods for
embedding
and we show that we can you know
overall you can do you can you can do
better uh the what we call our method is
hagashi can do better one of the
features of of our approach that you can
uh incorporate additional attributes on
the note right in the hyper graph each
node you can have additional attributes
and there's one data set where
this
data sets is the lee at all this is
actually co-assay data between single
cell high c and methylation if for each
node you also have their methylation
information uh as attribute uh you can
uh do even better in terms of the uh uh
separation of the complex cell type i'll
show you um one more uh result on this
like how
uh the type of advanced advances that
higashi is introducing to this type of
mouths in terms of separating
cell types in in complex tissues
now that's embedding but how about the
imputation
and imputation is is
tricky because we don't know ground
truth right you know you can do
simulation but how do you know the the
the
um
the contact map you're simulating are uh
realistic so one approach we uh took
here is to use the
um
imaging data so there's recent
development in imaging the 3d genome
using
you know
single molecule
based approaches and this has been to at
all
a
paper from xiaowei zhang's lab
they did
these 3d genome imaging for
for for for for the chromosomes so we
use this as the ground truth so that you
can look at the distances from imaging
you convert that into a content map like
this right so you can consider this as a
ground truth and then you downsample
that into
a
very sparse content matrix
so of course the computational goal
right now as the evaluation is you run
different approaches and see how much
you can recapitulate the original
patterns
and as we have shown here higashi you
know
can can can can do better than the
another method called uh singh is high
cluster which was developed in joe
ecker's lab a few years ago
both visually and also using
quantitative metrics
i forgot i want to mention one thing is
in higashi we can in the embedding space
we can also
borrow information
from each other among the cells in the
embedding space if the cells are close
to each other in the embedding space you
can try to borrow information between
them
so
one evaluation here is that if you
borrow information from neighboring
cells let's say four neighboring cells
you can achieve even better imputation
right as expected uh so as a
confirmation that you look at the
neighboring cells in the embedding space
you saw that their patents are very
similar to each other but if you look at
the
cells that are very far away from from
from from the cell that you're dealing
with in the embedding space their
contact patterns are very different
and
so here's um
some additional results to show you so
this is the original contact map this is
the imputed uh results and the
imputation allows you to have more
reliable analysis of the three genome
features like tab boundaries and
individual cells so the figure on the
right hand side
we show you the insulation scores which
which
measures the strength of the boundary of
of the domain
so
the lower
the score the stronger the boundary is
so as you can see without the imputation
then it's very noisy in terms of the
installation scores but after the
imputation you can more reliably call
the
installation scores that manifest the
tag boundaries and from this example we
show that there looks like there are you
know different types of
variability of the attack boundary in in
individual cells and the region
highlighted by the yellow box it looks
like there's a absence and presence of
the of the of the um domain boundary
where the region uh highlighted by the
red box it looks like the boundary is
shifting on the genome uh uh gradually
so these these could be the different
types of variability in terms of these
domain boundaries in individuals so one
is more more
absent than present the other is more
the changes are more more gradual
so this is what i mentioned to you the
application to a complex tissue in the
human prefrontal cortex
and um in the um um
um
you know this is one of the most
complicated complicated singles or high
c data sets so far and in the original
publication the authors
stated that if you only use single cell
high c part of their data you will not
be able to distinguish the subtypes of
excessive neurons inhibitor neurons
and
we revisited this this this statement
and we found that if you use hagashi
embeddings actually you can uh separate
the uh i think this is the uh accessory
neurons subtypes and then this is the
inhibitory neurons and you can separate
them into
finer scale
structures and if you use the av
compartment scores and also the
domain insulation scores that we
calculated from
the individual contact maps you are also
able to separate
these these uh
cell types
and based on the imputation of higashi
we also calculate the
tat boundaries for each single cell and
we are able to identify cell type
specific
uh bound as a cell type specific
features and the heat map here shows the
average you know single cell av
compartment values or the
single cell you know average single cell
insulation scores of the regions
surrounding um the surrounding marker
genes so each row
is um
you know here these are the marker genes
from
astrocytes and so for instance this is
the marker genes from neurons as you can
tell that the marker genes from these
particular cell types they have higher
uh a b compartment lazy compartmization
scores from from the higashi imputed uh
results and then
if you look more closely you can even
distinguish the
detailed
accessory neuron and inhibitory neural
subtypes based upon these
single cell level three genome features
calculated from higashi
so
the method also has some
quite major limitations which is also a
problem for
almost you know other existing single
cell analysis methods
first
some of the rail cell type
identification remains challenging
and so the embedding
itself could be improved second is
because this is more a
deep learning based
approach interpretability
remains
a roadblock and it lacks
in interpretability and we know that the
embedding is kind of good right it can
separate the cell types but we don't
know why it is why it is good
so it would be great if there is some
alternative approach that can provide um
additional perspective to that
finally um
you know as i listed on the right hand
side uh there i think it was mentioned
by cheyenne also yesterday for this
spatial transcript tone there's a trend
that these are these data sets are
getting increasingly large right
originally in the early publications um
the only you know the authors they only
published a few cells of this three
genome
structures but these days you know each
publication will have tens of thous
thousands uh at least thousands of cells
and and it is it is getting uh
increasingly large in terms of the cell
cell numbers so scale
the method has to be more scalable for
that
and here's our um
recent effort and we developed a method
called fast tagashi i won't get into the
uh details and it's actually on by
archive and i hope it will be published
soon in the journal
so we took a different approach so we
view the single cell contact maps as a
multi-way as sorry it's a
multi-three-way tensor
here you know um so you have this um
let's say
a three-way tensor so the contact maps
right contact map itself is
two-dimension and then it's across
different different different cells
and um this is really multiplied
applications of matrix decomposition for
1d single cell assays and we we
we developed this methods based on
tensor uh decomposition
so for each chromosome let's say this
chromosome one across different cells
it's going to be um decomposed into
two factors right one is the cell
embedding
and the other is what we call chromosome
specific meta interactions so matter
interaction is analogous to meta genes
for a single cell rna-seq
so what you can see here is that for so
r is a parameter that you can you can
tune in terms of how many you know
clusters or groups that you you expect
to see
and for uh cell cell embeddings and then
they will reflect different cell types
in from from the given data set
or and also the chromosome specific
matter interactions are going to capture
some
um collective
patterns
from each each contact map and then you
can look into that contact map to
interpret
why
you know what kind of features are
giving rise to
a particular uh cell type or what kind
of features are important for
determining a particular cell type and
then you can follow that with subsequent
analysis to
you know for each cell type you can then
integrate with other assays like single
cell attack or single cell rna seek to
connect structure and function so this
is actually what we are currently also
working on to see if you can
elaborate and then further develop this
approach by combining fastagashi with
higashi that i mentioned to you before
you can sometimes perhaps you can use
use fasagashi as an initiation for the
higashi because i got yourself is slow
but the imputation itself we think is
more advanced than uh the then the um
the component that we implemented in in
fast aigashi so again um if i have
interest please check out the uh archive
uh now so the last few minutes um i
would like to introduce you um
a software tool that we developed so it
is
um becoming very important
for
the 4d nuclear 3d epigenomics field to
present all these data in different
modalities to the user right for
hypothesis generation integrative
analysis
and you not only have bulk level assays
you have single cell genomic data you
also have imaging data time
how do you navigate these information in
more unified interface
it's it it's not possible yet
and um like you you have you know tools
like you use a c genome browser for
looking genomic tracks you have high
glass
to look at uh high c data you have you
know amaro amero to look at microscopy
imaging data but these tools have not
been connected to each other which is
what we try to achieve really the
integrated visualization and this is
also being done in the context of for
the nucleum
so our solution what we call a nuclear
bowser and then the paper itself will
come out in nature methods very soon
what we did here is to
really achieve what i mentioned to you
before we want to present a
unified interface to the user
where you don't have to go to different
tools you can just use this one
interface and you can arrange these into
in these these modules in any way you
want you can look at 3d genome
structures you can look at you know
genomic tracks you can look at the
microscopy images
i'll show you some demos so like you
know on the left hand side this is
genomic
browser right so different genomic
tracks and then you have these high c
contact maps and the probes will
correspond to the microscopy images the
experiments that have been done
and you may also load the
you know
structure models right from various
types of approaches you can look at uh
you can load external tools like high
glass which is more powerful to look at
these contact maps in a more scalable
way
and like ucsc genome browser has already
hosted vast amount of
data sets encode epigenetic roadmap it
doesn't make sense for us to reinvent
the world to store that information so
we just connect them and these kind of
operations are are
mutual so if you do something on
you know operate or highlight something
on the usage unit browser our system
will also respond and one important
implementation that we did recently is
to connect with uh jupyter notebook so
that you can you can really
significantly enhance the productivity
of
internet analysis you can just look at
the tracks and generate these blocks as
you move around the um
the um the digital browser so it is
often incredibly useful to look at your
data in different perspectives so here
i'm showing you that you can drag a
bigwig track where you have these
continuous
values rather than looking at them in
the in a in a one-dimensional track like
in conventional genome browsers you can
put them in the context of a structure
or you can look at you know their
interactions with other nuclear bodies
or their their their their positions in
nucleus
or you can compare these structures in
different cellular conditions here we're
comparing two different cell types uh h1
and also k5 system and you can you know
highlight the region one cell type and
then the other cell type will respond
and we also implemented a scatter plot
like this you know you can
select data points on the scatter plot
and then the genomic tracks going to
show you where these data points are and
you can also use this for a single cell
through your genome analysis which we
have already implemented this is on the
also the connection between the
genome browser and also the jupyter
notebook so
one thing i want to highlight is
so this is a unique feature where you
can actually connect the micros
microscopy imaging data stored in a
resource called idr um developed by my
uh our colleague jason swetlow in
university which is widely used in in in
the imaging community and we integrate
them with the genomic tracks
so here we're using a data set
from uh from
fei chen slab published last year in in
science where
this is a whole genome imaging data set
and the they're already or deposited
imaging data in idr so we didn't
grab those
files to our local server we just
remotely connect to them
so that you can see that these all these
operations are synchronized where you
can highlight the regions in the genome
browser or a probe in the imaging data
where the with their locations that
genome browser will be highlighted as
well and then you can certainly click
the details of the of the of the uh
probes and then look at their their uh
particular uh metadata
um i actually have uh this slide like
one is outlook for unsolved the problems
i think due to the limit of time i'm
gonna skip this so um uh so i
mentioned all these
folks name
during the course of my presentation and
then none of this will be possible
without the collaboration with many
colleagues in the for the nuclear
consortium
and also
funding sources thank you very much
it's great for her
looks like the community has sort of
given up on the inter-chromosomal
data which could be even sparser than
what
is the case or yeah so for fault level
uh there's there's you know you can use
you can see signals from intercoms or
contact laptops actually
uh work on that try to identify patterns
from into chromosomal complex sort of
these trends the trans uh interactions
between different chromosomes
so right now for single cell ic
is not quite feasible because of the
sparseness of the data you're not going
to see anything from the
interconsole
so can you make use of uh recent imaging
data for example from open cell also
live cell imaging of gfp fusion proteins
and computationally people can
distinguish different subcompartments in
the nucleus and seeing if those can map
to structures that you see with ic and
other kinds of methods yeah
if there is like
the way that we connect them right
there's there's some you need some
information to connect them
the information that we use to connect
them is the coordinates the genomic
coordinates right so if there is
you know
this kind of metadata available then it
is
it is doable because you can just store
the information in json swallows
repository
and you'll be able to will be able to
connect them and you can see the you
know the corresponding genomic tracks in
this platform yeah it just might link
some sort of protein complex machines
that are responsible for that
organization to
uh the data to the organization be cool
yes